and what I liked about this is after
this format was done and it settled
I was like I wonder what the internet's
gonna say yeah I was curious yeah I went
to Twitter and besides the the typical
PlayStation does everything right play
Xbox does everything wrong
everyone was co-signing this and that
that's what I like like and I went to
the people that you know that are that
are truly on both sides you know
PlayStation fans that that like the Xbox
brand but they're just not happy with
the Xbox brand right now and even those
people I didn't see no like huge you
know back backlash or anything like that
for the most part it was if they did
have issues with it it was criticism it
was constructive criticism I didn't see
a whole lot of people just hating on
this game to hate on this game and I
think that's important yeah no format
format was key so um we're gonna get
into which we'll get into now the actual
game shown